right so we have a new trailer for venom
like an actual trailer for venom where
we actually see venom cuz the internet
was like well it's like Sony was like
[ __ ] fine guys here it was really funny
if I'm getting ahead of myself isn't the
chatter that you only see venom for a
few minutes in this movie which means
that I don't know might be the end of
the movie nothing is more Sony movie
trailer than showing the end like what
if that's the last shot gonna make a
prediction now that guy does not live
through that but in this trailer for
venom we see Tom Hardy do seems like a
pretty good dude he's an investigative
journalist who's given the heart he's
thrown the hardball questions to this
one dude works at this company happy to
CEO who knows and he's like is it true
that you find people who are down on
their luck and do experiments on them
that killed them guys like we're done
we're done which seems like he's a
pretty good humanitarian for doing that
[ __ ] that's a far cry from being a
photographer who faked a photo at the
Daily Bugle I do like the tone of the
fact that he's not feeling too well it
feels kind of ill because we never
really explore that when Eddie Brock got
that thing was he just totally cool or
does this thing take him over and just
like I feel well which means definitely
spider-man's not part of this universe
that was one of the things I'm like that
changes Venom's character of the fact
that it's not on spider-man first so he
doesn't hate spider-man nor does he have
the spider symbol on him so this is
actually kind of a plain black suit
let's have white veins though that's
neat looking but when Spiderman got that
suit he was pretty spry right out the
gate it wasn't like oh sorry Secret Wars
I just don't feel too well you guys go
on without me
I don't feel well mom I can't go to work
I can't go to school I just need to play
more God award actually this whole
trailer we don't see any webs on him he
probably doesn't even have webs but it
does look like it's a horror alien movie
with a parasite which is funny this dude
on Twitter totally read my mind on this
[ __ ] or maybe I read his mind maybe it's
a herb maybe I read her mind maybe she
read my mind point is they were like are
you seeing the trailer for upgrade in
this trailer as well yep I am dude has a
voice in his head his body gets taken
over and he kicks people's asses honey I
never thought that there was a voice in
Eddie Brock's head I always thought it
was more or less a feeling or if there
was a voice it was like Doc Ock and the
Raimi spider-man 2 whereas more or less
he hears the voice but we don't hear the
boys this one's like this lady who's
following him who gets him into it she's
like we found these things we call them
symbiosis I was like I've always
pronounced it symbiote like symbionts
symbiote I don't maybe I'm pronouncing
it wrong to be honest with you at this
moment right now I'm not 100% sure what
they're not Eddie Brock here's to
symbiote voicings I feel like I'm
mistaking jit now the world were
apparently they don't know that Venom's
voice sounds like ten voices at once
coming out not one deep low voice maybe
it's a tomato tomahto thing I feel like
it's a little closer to pronouncing Aang
wrong like why one is a lot of 10 drills
or working the scene he's like alright
we just got to take out bad guys that's
what you're gonna do you're gonna take
out [ __ ] you're not gonna take how
good people was just part of the
struggle with Eddie Brock in venom Eddie
Brock's like I control you you don't
control me we are we will work together
but we're not killing innocents ladies
Cassidy guess that thing becomes carnage
he's like I'll just kill everybody in
fact we'll get so bonded I'll say I I
did love the fact that he said we I was
actually really good lying does it say
that
that's pretty venom right there that
scene
in a world where we have superheroes out
there that need to go another direction
I'll Harbor a movie antihero I'm
actually down for this movie might be
terrible but I'm crossing my fingers on
this one I'm rooting for this movie for
nothing else all right so the trailer
for venom have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]